shira's math test included a survey
question asking how many hours students
had spent studying for the test the
graph below shows the relationship
between how many hours students spent
studying and their score on the test
shera drew the line below to show the
trend in the data
assuming the line is correct what does
the line slope of 15 mean
so let's see the horizontal axis is time
studying in hours vertical axis is
scores on the test and each of these
blue dots represent the time and the
score for a given student so this
student right over here spent i don't
know it looks like they spent about .6
hours studying and they didn't do too
well on the exam they look like they got
below a 45 looks like a 43 or 44 on the
exam
this student over here spent almost four
and a half hours studying and got looks
like a 94 90 close to a 95 on the exam
and what shira did is try to draw a line
that tries to fit this data it seems
like it does a pretty good job of
getting of at least showing the trend in
the data
now slope of 15 means that if i'm on the
line so let's say i'm here and if i
increase in the horizontal direction by
one so there i increased by the
horizontal direction by one i should be
increasing in the vertical direction by
15 and you see that if we increase by
one hour here we increase by 15 percent
on the test
now what that means is that the trend it
shows is that in general along this
trend
if someone studies an extra hour then if
we're going with that trend then hey you
know it seems reasonable that they might
expect to see a 15
gain on their test now let's see which
of these are consistent
in general students who didn't study at
all got scores of about 15 on the test
well let's see this is this is neither
true
we don't see these are the people who
didn't study at all and they didn't get
15 on the test and that's definitely not
what this 15 implies this doesn't say
what the what the people who didn't
study at all get so this one is not true
that one is not true if let's try this
one if one student studied for one hour
more than another student the student
who studied more got exactly 15 more
points on the test well this is getting
closer to the spirit of what the slope
means but this word exactly is what at
least in my mind messes this choice up
because this isn't saying that it's
guaranteed that if you study an hour
extra that you'll get 15 percent more on
the test this is just saying that this
is the general trend that this line is
seeing so it's not it's not guaranteed
for example we could find this student
here who studied exactly two hours and
if if we look at the students who
studied for three hours well there's no
one exactly at three hours but some of
them so this was let's see the study
student was at two hours you go to three
hours
there's no one exactly there but no one
there's going to be students who got
better than what would be expected and
students who might get a little bit
worse notice there's points above the
trend line and there's points below the
trend line so this exactly you can't say
it's guaranteed an hour more turns into
let's try this choice in general
studying for one extra hour was
associated with the 15 point improvement
in test score that feels about right
in general studying for 15 extra hours
was associated with a one point
improvement in test score we know that
would get the slope the other way around
so that's definitely not the case let's
check our answer and we got it right